gosh you don't know me you don't know  anything  yeah I loved  [Music]  you  get off my farm  I need you to help me  and we better start over don't you I  haven't seen you in three years you make  me say that's not an ideal come on just  a note are you pregnant  just a little Suzie beans  oh no we mustn't give up our beans well  if you show them enough are you sure  this is like say comes in flashes ready  [Music]  I'll forgive me I've never been the back  end of the spiral before it suits here  very well thank you  [Music]  all righty I'm a bad influence both  people we're gonna have to see what can  be done about that okay fine you know I  can't I can't you're right these are the  wrong shoes and gonna twist an ankle  oh yes  [Music]  we go  [Music]  you